i will thanks thanks for
having me here the first slide is about
me I'm an economist I try to find a
joyful picture of me and there was this
app which puts taglines pictures with
the joyful face I would say living la
vida loca and as an economist as a PhD
student I start to be interested in
theory first but as it usually happens
nowadays in my field economics people
started being interested in theory but
they move slowly toward data analysis
and here is where Python and also other
programs like R and theta can come in my
current research focus is on the housing
market and this is what I'm going to
talk today the structure of the talk
would be personally introduction then I
will talk about the data that I use in
my research the matching procedure where
I put together different data sets from
different sources to get some
interesting result out of them then some
findings then some more matching and
then the summary and the way the way
forward I'm not going to talk a lot
about specific snipers of of course i
will be talking more about the kind of
things that can be done with the data on
house prices and rents that is currently
out there so if you are from the UK you
already know this if you are not from
the UK you have to know this is a an
ounce price obsessed country we talk
about us prices every day in every
social encounter and so this is the dist
oak fits this despite them so my the
thing that I wanted to study is the
relationship between prices and rents
also we can indicate it as the price
when ratio as some people measure it or
also as more people measurable
the ratio between rent and prices also
called the rental yield and you can
immediately see that this measure for
many people is crucial because if you
are a household and you are deciding
whether to buy or to rent your
accommodation and clearly the ratio
between prices and rents is very
important also if you are a landlord or
an investor and you want to know what
will be the return of buying a property
then also this measure is crucial so
what is usually done in analysis is to
measure this ratio at the aggregate
level so in newspapers this is the in
magazines like The Economist we often
see a time series of aggregate prices
versus aggregate rents and when prices
are high with respect to rents we think
the market is overvalued when prices are
low with respect to rent we think the
market is under valid but again this is
only an aggregate measure and it is a
time series measure what is less no but
it's equally important that if we go
from the time series measure to a
cross-sectional way of analyzing these
things we see that not only the rent
price ratio varies over time but they're
very big differences in rent price
ratios across geographical areas this is
taken from the Financial Times this is
London and as you can see the rental
yields are generally higher in the more
peripheral postcode of London whereas in
the most most expensive areas we have
rental yields between 0 and four percent
so prices are very high with respect to
rent or rents are cheap with respect to
prices in the more expensive areas now
when companies an institution do
analysis like this they take the average
price for say two bedroom properties and
they compare it with the average
for two bedroom properties so it's still
an aggregate analysis and we might think
that the average property for sale two
bedroom property for sale is different
perhaps as a higher quality that the
average property for rent the average
two bedroom property for rent so these
measures are fine but they're not
perfect ideally we would like to measure
the price and the rent on the same exact
property and this is what I do in my
research so why this is the only formula
of the talk why should rent price ratio
be different across different locations
and why should they change over time
well in economics will have no arbitrage
conditions because they tell us it's not
it is impossible to make extra profits
in the market so in equilibrium the rent
the amount of money paid by an
individual as rain should be equal to
the user cost of owning a property the
user cost is the cost of keep keeping
the property for one year and it depends
on the interest rate the risk the
expected growth and maintenance the
reason I'm showing these form is to say
well if we see that the rent price ratio
changes over time and across space it
must be that it's because these things
change so interest rates change over
time maintenance costs can be different
across different types of properties and
expected growth and risk clearly are
different both over time and also across
space so in my analysis i use any two
sources of data clearly one is house
prices the other is private sector rent
now house prices is the easy part
because we now have the Land Registry
price paid data has been released last
year the entire data set start in 1995
until 2013 this is an incredible for
people starting the housing market is
incredibly useful data set it's 18.5
million records and with these variables
we have the full address of properties
the price paid the date the properties
were sold etc when I started this
research this data was not available
however at the London School of
Economics we used to buy the land range
data set and we add the data until 2011
for my research a really put pressure on
the department to buy the data for 2012
as soon as they both the data they spent
a lot of money the land price released
the data for three to two weeks later so
now for the next five years I will avoid
asking them to buy new data sets okay so
some insight can already be seen by
simply plotting the data so these are
all the saints in London from 2006 to
2012 plotted i stopped at 1 million
pound this is just a simple moving
average and the moving average already
gives you an idea of where prices are
going this this is similar to the price
indices we see we see in the name in the
newspapers or in magazines and some
interesting patterns emerge right it's
very difficult to see transactions
around the first of January to the first
of December so you see the we have these
white lines here and also we have this
horizontal white lines corresponding to
these very specific prices 250,000 and
500,000 so why is that yeah exactly the
stamp duty is really really important to
understand the distribution of house
prices stamp duty jumps I think from
three percent to four percent at 500,000
so no one sells the house at 500 1500
five pounds
so people are rational in the price they
said on the market now the problem is
data on private ranks here i'm quoting a
review an official review by the
national statisticians was saying a gap
exists in official private rental
statistics so if there is something that
is missing today in for people that are
starting the housing market is good data
on private rents there is a hope for the
future because in 2013 very recently the
office for national statistics released
an index for the for product ranson is
based on valuation of his agency data so
this agency employs rental officers that
go around the country and ask people how
much is the rent so this potentially
could be in the future the Land Registry
of rains let's say but for now the data
is not available so we have to find
different sources so when when this is
the case where you you don't have the
data you have to ask so I asked around
and I find people willing to listen at
John davillon company which is a private
real estate agency it has offices in
London and the countryside it deals with
central South West London and it's in
general an aftermarket agency however
real estate agencies have data on
private rents so that was great for my
my research so this is a map of the
rents they have in their data set day
they only have new contracts so that
potential is sometimes a problem not for
my research because clearly they only
have data on rental contracts that go
through real estate agents so if you
renew your contract it won't be in the
system they have their own rental
contracts are also data from other
agencies and you see this is the area of
London that they cover these oars are
the parts Hyde Park and Regent Park and
so this is in this research the area
that I analyze this is the data on rent
again just by plotting a weekly rent so
you can see this is an expensive area of
London so the average will collect
weekly rent is between 400 and 600 and
this is sort of an index of what rents
are doing in this period so the matching
so the idea here is to match prices from
the land registry with rent from this
agency and measure the price rent ratio
for individual properties you probably
know this much better than me so
sometimes matching the different data
set is easy and sometimes it's more
difficult so so the land registry has
this information postcode primary
addressable object secondary addressable
object and Street sometimes these
entities corresponds perfectly to what
is in the agency data sometimes it is
more complicated so usually it's easy to
match houses it's much more difficult to
match flats because when you deal with
flats you have the flat number you have
the street number sometimes you have the
building name and it's not always clear
what is what so in this case Marsh court
561 and for it's not immediately clear
if four is the street number or the flat
number etc so we have all these products
and often this data is compiled by agent
so often the variables are in the wrong
place this Robert Rupert house is
probably the name of the building not
the address and so there is some manual
work involved in the matching but once
the matching
is the answer so this is what I just
said what I do is clearly since there
are repeat sales and repeat rents on the
same property for each sale I keep only
the closest rent for each rental
contract I keep only the closet to close
a sale this is a bar chart of how many
days I see in my match properties
between the sale and the first rental
contract so this graph may make sense
because conditional on there being a
match between a sale and rental contract
most of the matches are our clothes
which means these are probably buy to
let properties they were sold and then
they were rented out we don't have many
rental contracts starting just before
the house is sold and this makes sense
because why would you start rental
contract just before you set the house
so I focus only on these very close
matches where I can say that the price
the rent were measured at approximately
the same time so I have a good measure
of the ratio between prices and rents
now the good thing about private data
sets on rent in this case on rentals but
in general is that we have met many more
information many more attributes housing
attributes with respect to the Land
Registry so when I match with the Land
Registry with my agency data set I know
the floor level of the property these
are some statistics to compare my
complete data set and the match data set
and I also have other variables like
number of bedrooms whether the property
the belong stone apartment block the
floor area weather is furnished on
furnished these things are important
when analyzing house prices and house
rents in terms of results so these are
these dots are my match properties so
properties were
I have price and rent and on the
vertical axis I have the rental yield so
the average rental yield in this part of
London has been around five percent
between 2006 and 2012 but it has been
declining which means both rents and
prices have been going up recently but
prices have been going up more than
rents and therefore the rental yield has
been going down if you remember the
formula for the rental yield the rental
yield depends among other things on the
interest rate so if you plot one measure
of the interest rate the 10-year UK
government bond yield you see that it
has been declining in consistently with
the decline in housing rental yields now
a very important finding is this one
again on the vertical axis have the
rental yield on the horizontal axis here
I have prices and here I have read so
the message of these plots is in general
more expensive properties have lower
rental yields so when you go from a
cheap property to an expensive property
both rents and prices go up but prices
go up more in relative terms than rent
therefore the ratio between rents and
prices is around two three percent for
properties above let's say 12 million
pounds very expensive properties but it
goes up for cheap properties it starts
around six you see there is a clear
negative relation and the same goes for
rent now because if you compare the
ratio between rental prices with prices
you mechanically have a negative
relation so you might not trust this
plot but if you compare the rent price
ratio with rents you would expect a
positive relation is that the relation
is still negative so this is an
important thing
an important stylized fact in the
housing market that is not often
discussed now if we on the horizonte
Laxus instead of price we what we would
be so this this pattern is evident both
in apartments and houses and also for
big properties and small properties so
the bigger the property the higher is
the price of course the higher is the
rent but the price the prices go up more
than rents and the same with postcodes
the more expensive the postcode the
lower the rental yield and these are
just bivariate relations I can run a
multivariate regression on all
properties property attributes and I
find the same the same fact the same
pattern so in terms of explanation for
these patterns I'll talk about risk and
expected return but one thing that is
often I think overlooked is the role of
maintenance costs or if maintenance is
not paid depreciation the price of the
property will go down so why is that the
more central more expensive areas the
rental yield is is lower so you can
think of house prices as the sum of two
things one is the price of the land on
which the house is built and the other
is the price of the structure now the
structure varies little between one
location and the other two to build the
same house here outside London or in
Chelsea will cost in terms of materials
and labor the cost will be more or less
the same whereas what really change
changes is the price of land but if you
think about maintenance and depreciation
these
these expenses expenses relate to the
structure not to the land so we're in
expensive areas as a percentage term
maintenance and depreciation are less
important than in cheaper areas and this
is an important factor that that drives
the difference differences in rental
yields now to measure to measure the
effect of appreciation and risk on the
rental yield I need to do more matching
this time not with not between data set
but within data set so there are
properties that sell repeatedly and
profits that get rented repeatedly and
if I can measure the appreciation
between one sale and the next one
between one rent and the next one I can
measure the appreciation for that
specific property and this is important
for my for my research it turns out that
repeat sales are not that easy to find
in the data because the average you can
sort stays in an owner occupied property
for I think ten years so with not much
of a time window it's difficult to find
repeat says it's much easier once you
have rental data to find repeat rents on
the same property and this is very
useful to measure how rents appreciate
over time so this was my match data set
where I find a sale and the rental on
the same property so i find i found
2000s data points almost 2000 data
points now within those problem with in
that sample i look for rent on the same
property so i want for the same property
first sale than rental and then another
renter in the future so like so that i
can measure the rental yield
also how much rents have grown over time
if the theory is correct when four
properties were more where growth has
been higher in in the subsequent years
then the rental yield should have been
lower in when it was measured and indeed
i find that future rent appreciation
predict the rental yields another thing
that i can measure using repeat rents is
the volatility of rains how does with
respect to the same city as a
london-wide index how many individual
rents are going up and down how
unpredictable and volatile they are now
Theory here is ambiguous because
volatile rents on one hand should bring
down prices because investors don't like
volatility don't like unprotect when
something is unpredictable but on the
other hand if friends are volatile
consumers households will prefer owning
rather than renting and therefore could
this could push up prices and indeed
when I measure the volatility in rent
appreciation I don't find any relation
with the rental yield so to sum up my
findings also this this is a way to to
exploit one data set that is public that
is freely available the land registry
and a private private data set on rent
to measure rental yields and I find that
rent price ratios rental yields are
lower for more expensive properties and
this is true both in the sense that
bigger properties have lower rent price
ratios but also that property is located
in more expensive areas of lower rent
price ratios
and this is consistent with economic
theory this is just the beginning of my
research agenda so the Land Registry the
bottom line is I think the land registry
is a recent open data resource with a
huge potential and it is it is a
platform a starting point and one can
merge all sorts of property based data
onto the land registry and find
important important things about the
housing the housing market this analysis
is on central London the goal is to
expand it outside to explain to the
world UK but for doing so to do that I
need new data sets and I think i will
try to contact website they have many a
lot of information on rents and prices
and property attributes and perhaps
other other agencies so I think if
anyone here in the audience is
interested in doing research on house
prices in using the Land Registry let's
just get in touch and I'm sure there are
many many many things to be to be done
in this in this field okay thank you